[Musique]
se qualifier et prendre du plaisir un
objectif majeur pour les participantes
cette nouvelle édition du championnat de
départemental de gymnastique artistique
féminine réunissait 21 clubs yvelinois
au gymnaste Pierre de Coubertin de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux les enjeux pour
elle c'est ce qualifier pour la suite
des compétitions c'est à dire pour
l'Inter des départementales celle qui
vont se qualifier et pour les autres
elles iront en département en
département 2 qui va se situer à peu
près vers le mois de mars il y en a qui
sont très fortes et qui qui bossent pour
l'être et il y a beaucoup l'esprit de
famille un rendez-vous annuel pour les
350 participantes âgés de 8 à 18 ans la
gymnastique artistique féminine permet
assez sportive de développer
coordination force et souplesse en toute
normalement le même niveau là c'est le
département donc c'est la première donc
elle ne font pas tout tout leur
mouvement et au fur et à mesure qu'on va
monter dans l'année jusqu'à la finalité
là elles ont elles vont tout envoyer
leur mouvement définitif on est pas mal
sorti par rapport à d'autres que l'année
dernière elles étaient plus fortes mais
non cette année j'ai l'impression elles
doivent être tous stressées quatre des
six équipes de Montigny gym ont terminé
sur le podium lors de ce championnat la
médaille d'or a été décrochée une
satisfaction pour le club qui réalise
des résultats comparables à l'année
précédente
[Musique]